right now you've heard the crushing news
about our colleague and dear friend
Charles Krauthammer I have only a few
weeks left to live Charles wrote in one
of his final letters this is the final
verdict my fight is over well over the
coming days Charles will be celebrated
and ultimately eulogized by those who
knew him for generations who will
continue to touch and guide those who
didn't know him his words clear and
crisp and true will long outlive him a
lot will be said about Charles
Krauthammer I'd like to add just one
thing over the more than 20 years that I
knew him Charles thought about death
every day he told me that once
if that sounds morose it was just the
opposite because he was one of those
rare people with the courage to look
realities wearily in the face
Charles radiated a calm cheerfulness he
knew what was coming he'd been very
close to it before he didn't want to
leave but it didn't scare him Charles
Krauthammer is a genuinely brave man for
that reason he's a happy man
I live the life that I intended he wrote
and there is no higher achievement than
that good night have a great weekend
you